Hi, I'm Jeffrey Brown and I'm a scout master with Chook 273 in Union City, California.
This edition of the Scout Master Podcast is sponsored by Backers Like Me.
And now it's the old scout master.
Shane Adams woke up at summer camp one foggy morning and he wanted to catch some fog to
show to his scouts, but he missed
Missed
Fog.
Yoo-hoo-hoo,
Listen, nobody should be hazing their scouts anyway, right?
Hey, this is podcast number 312..
Hey,
Welcome back to the Scout Master Podcast.
This is Clark Green
In the mailbag this week.
Oh, over on Amazon, a review from my book. So Far, So Good, A 5 Star Review,
If I do say so myself- and I do-
From Eric Herning and Imperial Beach, California.
And Eric said honestly, I was hoping for more of an instruction manual for a new scout master.
I was pleasantly surprised at how well the narrative flowed from scout meeting to scout meeting,
touching on the author's experience,
And I reflected on my own troop while reading the book
And, while not yet a scout master, felt it prepared me to be a scout master,
Learning that being the scout master is more than just knowing how to lead, but how to teach the scouts to lead.
I'd recommend this book to anyone.
Well, thanks so much, Eric,
I appreciate that
And, yes, So Far, So Good is definitely not a training manual.
It's not a step-by-step how to do things,
And here's the deal right.
This is why I wrote it the way that I did,
Because how do you learn the kind of soft skills- I guess you would call them soft skills-
that a scout master needs are things that you really can't reduce to like step 1,, 2,, 3..
And you can't do in a training course or anything like that.
It's something that you have to work at, an experience,
And I had 30 years experience with it.
I felt like I got reasonably good at it
And after trying to get all this in writing to show somebody what I'm talking about,
the best form ended up being a story.
Who knew?
But no, Eric, I really appreciate the review.
Every week I try and have a couple of live chat sessions, usually Tuesday and Wednesday mornings.
They're held at scoutmasterscgcom.
I'll announce when I'm going to be online on my Facebook feed and my Twitter feed.
Come on over say hello,
Join in with the rest of the many, many scouts who sign in each week.
Some of them we call frequent fliers because they come back again and again,
And this past week, Rob checked in with us from North Plainfield, New Jersey.
He's an assistant scout master of Troop 235 and the committee chair of PAC 135..
And Rob visited with us for his first time, as did Matt Thompson,
who is with Troop 216 in Eureka, Kansas, where he's the committee chairman,
and Hugh Biscoe, who is in Sycamore, Illinois, with Troop 18,
where he's the scout master in PAC 141 and he's active at the district level
and all kinds of things like. a lot of scouts are.
Thanks for stopping in and saying hello for the first time.
You can join them this coming week.
This coming week, look Tuesday and Wednesday mornings,
Watch the Facebook feed and the Twitter feed.
Come join us at scoutmastercgcom for a live chat.
Now, if you stop by and you check out scoutmastercgcom
and you listen to the podcast and you're getting something out of it,
well, you can help me keep them all up and running by becoming a backer
or by becoming a patron,
Two very simple ways to lend us a little support.
If you want to check them out, go to scoutmastercgcom.
Look up at the top of the page, the very top menu,
You'll see a support link
That'll take you to different ways that you can become a backer,
which is making kind of a one-time subscription payment,
And also right there you'll see a link to Patreon, P-A-T-R-E-O-N,
where you can become a patron, which is an ongoing commitment
to make a monthly subscription payment of $5 or more.
So do that for me this week. Just at least check it out,
No pressure. okay,
If you're getting something out of this and you'd like to help out,
I'd really appreciate it.
And I want to take a moment this week to personally thank Bob Tribucci,
Steven Siruti and Edward Guzman for becoming backers
since last week, since our last podcast
Once again, scoutmastercgcom. right there at the top of the page
There's a support link, There's a Patreon link. Check it out.
This week's podcast is all about summer camp.
Yes, it is only April, but we might as well start thinking
about what summer camp is going to do for us this year
and how to prepare ourselves.
So I've got a message for scouters
and I've got a message for scout parents
And that's going to take up the remainder of the podcast.
so let's get started, shall we?
In this summer camp special podcast,
I want to play for you something I recorded about three years ago:
10 things that scouts can do to make summer camp really successful
and comfortable and a lot of fun.
Won't be too long before we're all packed up
and ready to take our big crowd of scouts to summer camp.
I am looking forward to it, as I do every summer.
This will be summer number 29, or summer maybe 29..
Yeah, I think summer number 29..
A lot of those summers my role at summer camp was being on staff
instead of being the scout master for our troop.
I did that for about a dozen years in different senior positions
and a couple of those were as the camp director.
That many years of working at camp
and the couple of years being a camp director
and keeping up with our current staff-
and I can tell you something:
things haven't changed a great deal.
The program, though, that changes a lot.
The program, though, that changes a little bit.
and you know, different people come,
but the same issues are the perennial issues,
that kind of make or break your week at summer camp.
We've attended the same summer camp
since the troop was first chartered in the 1940s.
Some of you like to go to different camps every year,
try out different things, you know, and that's all good.
I don't think there's a right or a wrong way to do it.
The right thing is getting out for a week at summer camp.
After all those years on staff and having spent a long time
as a scout master at camp and watching you know
literally thousands of scout leaders
and tens of thousands of scouts go through a summer camp week-
I can tell you- I believe, authoritatively-
that these are the most important things
for you to be thinking about. as an adult
who's going to spend a week at camp.
The number one thing is: don't overdo it
and kind of make yourself into a time bomb. okay,
If you get hungry or hot and tired and thirsty,
you need to pay attention to that
and you need to get cool and rested and fed and hydrated.
I know I get pretty cranky if I don't look after myself,
and years of observation prove
that many of my fellow scouters share the same problem.
When you're going to spend a week at camp
with a group of scouts,
the temptation is going to be to try to keep up with them.
Now, more power to you if you can do that
and not feel any effects.
but most of us aren't 16 anymore, right?
So we have to look after ourselves
and looking after yourself. most importantly,
that you get hydrated and rested
is really, really important
because if you turn yourself into this kind of ticking time bomb
so that by the end of the week you have no patience left
and you're getting a little touchy
and you're getting kind of cranky,
it's going to make everybody's life miserable.
So that's probably that's the number one thing
and that's why it's at the top of the list.
Number two: I can tell you that the camp staff
is totally dedicated to making your stay at camp worthwhile.
I can tell you that I know that
I've been to natural camp school-
I think I went to five different years of that-
and I know people from camps all over the country
and I know that they put their heart into it.
None of them are in it for the money-
The money is not good-
but they're there because they want to make this
a great experience for the scouts
and, in turn, for the adults
that are accompanying the scouts there.
One of the great experiences at a summer camp
are the younger people who are on the staff of the camp.
They're learning and growing just like your scouts are,
and you need to be considerate and supportive of them.
That is a really important way to make life better
while you're at camp: to be considerate
and supportive of the staff,
because that's what they're trying to do for you.
Number three: no matter how much you think they deserve it,
never berate or criticize or argue with
or yell at a staff member,
a youth leader or a fellow adult leader
in the presence of your scouts.
If it really needs to happen,
a quiet talk at an appropriate distance,
out of earshot from scouts,
will usually solve the problem
and a lot of times, if you're like me,
you're going to find out- the problem might be yours.
Number four is not to pull rank.
You should understand what that means.
Let's say you're a scout master
and you go down to camp with your troop.
Well, you're a scout master,
You're not a general or an admiral or the president,
so there really isn't any rank for you to pull, is there?
Most people instantly respect the position
that adults occupy at camp.
The staff respects it and the scouts respect it.
Don't make a big giant deal out of it.
Don't ask for special privileges
or try to impress staff members
with your self-importance
or your encyclopedic knowledge
of the things that they are doing.
They're very proud of what they are doing,
They're working hard to do it
and you going in there
and telling them. everything you know about it
is not necessarily going to be very welcome.
I'm in a situation where
I used to be the camp director at the camp
and I used to be on staff.
I've been going there longer than any staff member has
right at this point.
but I don't expect to be treated much differently
than any other scout leader
and it's important that I keep that attitude
and that I play the game
and I go by the rules
and I don't expect any special favors.
Number five is: join in the program
and encourage your scouts to join in too.
If you travel around,
if you go to a different camp every year,
you're going to hit a program that you don't like.
It's almost inevitable.
You're going to hit a program
that maybe, in your humble opinion, isn't all that great
and a staff that's not all that great.
I got to tell you from the staff side of things.
a lively, appreciative, supportive audience
does more than anything
to enliven and energize a camp staff.
Just being nice,
Even when things are going wrong,
Even when you think things are not great
and maybe even that you're being mistreated,
it doesn't cost much to be nice.
There is a nominal kind of customer relationship, right,
You plunk down money
and your scouts plunk down money to go to camp
and you expect a certain level of service
and accommodation and things like that.
Well, you know, let's remember,
a scout camp is not club med
and a scout camp is not necessarily going to be
a highly polished professional atmosphere
of, you know, absolute excellence.
Camp staffs go through cycles,
They have down years and they have up years
and camps go through cycles like that.
You know, the whole idea in all of this-
and I am saying is being a little humble
and being cooperative
and not complaining and grousing
and being kind of that disgruntled customer-
If you have a very bad experience,
you'll want to talk to somebody.
but I got to tell you the 15-year-old staff member,
the guys that are working at camp,
they're not the ones that are going to be able to change things.
You want to get in touch with somebody at the council office.
you want to talk to the camp director. maybe,
like I said, your attitude
is going to have a great deal to do
with the quality of your experience.
Number six is to participate
in ceremonies and traditions and practices of the camp,
even if they're not very familiar to you.
and you know, I'll say again,
even if you really don't care for them all that much.
A camp staff is very proud of its traditions.
Imposing your way of doing things
on a camp staff,
imposing your traditions on them,
is really kind of rude.
It's like going into somebody else's house
and rearranging the furniture.
Play along,
There's going to be a specific way
that a camp take, you know, has a retreat ceremony
and that's going to be a tradition that they've had
and developed over a number of years
and it's what people are used to
and you know it. may
there may be little details of it
that rub you the wrong way,
but listen, play along, Have a good time.
You know the way that they do a campfire,
the way things are done in the dining hall,
the way that merit badge sessions are set up.
go along with it and do your best
to encourage your scouts to do the same.
Number seven: you want to keep an eye
on any kind of inner-true rivalries
that may develop.
You know, for the most part
your scouts are going to be out and about
pretty much independently during the day
and they're going to be running into other scouts
and you have absolutely no control
over what other scouts are going to do
and you have, you know, only a little bit of control
over what your scouts are going to do
or say. and boys are boys
and they get real competitive
and sometimes that can lead to things
that aren't very productive.
so you want to watch out.
I'm not saying that any of this is necessarily negative,
but often with scout age boys,
the idea of sportsmanship
is not necessarily always foremost in their mind.
so you want to talk about that
and you want to check in on that
and make sure that your scouts,
at least that, are very sports-like
and fair-minded and courteous.
Number eight is something that we say all the time:
give your youth leaders all the responsibility for success.
see that they understand what needs to be done at camp,
how and why it needs to be done,
and then let them at it
and observe from a distance.
check in with them every evening,
check in with them every afternoon,
check in with them every morning,
ask lots of questions,
make sure that they are familiar with the program
and they're looking for somebody in charge.
I send them to the senior patrol leader
and the senior patrol leader works with the patrol leaders
and they have a great time at it,
because summer camp is a great patrol building time.
you can really make something out of that opportunity
if you give the youth leaders the full responsibility
for making their week a success.
Number nine is: be proud of your scouts
and encourage them and congratulate them and admire them,
but don't try to be one of them.
remember you're the coach, you're not a player.
get on the field. don't try and join in the youth activities.
let the scouts enjoy them.
every once in a while
the opportunity to jump in at the scout level
may present itself,
but don't interfere.
and I have seen that type of thing happen
a great deal at camp.
you know it's exciting and it's fun
and the scouts are having a great time
and then the adults decide
that they want to do the same type of thing.
it doesn't work really well.
keep an eye on that.
Number ten is: be patient with yourself.
be patient with your scouts,
be patient with the camp staff.
don't sacrifice the perfectly good
for the perfect.
here's this kind of thing that happens
when a scouter goes to camp
and he's very closely identified with his scouts
and the troop and everything like that,
and every little thing seems to matter:
the way the boys walk around camp,
what they do at a retreat ceremony,
the way that they act in the dining hall
is some kind of personal reflection
back on the scouter,
and scouts can get a little testy about that
and they get defensive about it.
it really tends to color
the whole way that they're approaching
the camp experience.
the camp is there for the scouts.
they'll take care of you,
they'll help you.
they'll probably even have some activities
especially for scouts to do.
in the end, you've got to be patient,
you've got to roll with the punches
and don't take yourself all
that seriously.
so those are 10 things
that, from my experience as a scout master
and as a camp director,
I hope will help you have a great week
at summer camp.
so I hope you found that helpful.
summer camp is a great place.
I hope those 10 things will help you think it through
a little bit.
now I want to share with you
something I recorded
a couple years ago
back in. well, it's 2014.
this was originally aired on
podcast 228.
now we're pretty good at getting ourselves
ready to go to camp
and getting our scouts ready to go to camp
and all the administrativa
and all the logistics
of preparing right.
but one of the things we may miss
is preparing the parents
who are not going,
who are sending their children with us to summer camp.
what are they going to be dealing with that week
and how can they help their scouts
better prepare?
so here's something I recorded a couple years ago,
in 2014, that talks about
just that.
you know, I have seen
that worried. look,
so many times
it happens just after parents
have brought their scout down to camp
and they have gone in,
they see the tent that he's going to be staying in
and they kind of look around a little bit
and they look at me
and the other adults are going to be staying there during the week
and they kind of reluctantly
start dragging
their feet up the trail
and they look
a little uncertain
that they're ready to do this
themselves.
most of the time the scouts- they're not even thinking
right
because they're at camp, they're happy,
they're there with their buddies and they're looking forward to a great week.
but parents sometimes,
hey, this can
catch them by surprise
because they concentrate a lot on preparing
their scout to go to camp
but they may be unaware of
the fact that, hey, this is going to hit them a little bit.
they are
leaving their child
at a camp
in the care of people who they may know
really well and maybe not know
really well, and they
may feel a little uncomfortable
turning over full-time
care of their child to somebody
who they've just gotten to know
and they're going to
worry about what kind of food
the scout will be eating
and who will be looking after daily concerns
like clean clothes
and taking showers and making sure they eat
and making sure they don't get hurt,
and they kind of wonder if the older
scouts are going to be nice
or if they're going to tease them.
hey, you know, if you've had this experience,
I really don't have to explain it to you.
I mean, what happens if you take your child
to camp and they just don't like camp?
can they call home
or can you check in on them?
oh, it can be really,
really anxious,
and I have seen this anxiety in parents
of scouts headed to camp for the first time
for many, many years.
many of those parents
find the experience more difficult
than their children do,
and if they wait for the first
contact from camp, the first letter
home, they don't find
a lot of solace in that either,
because it may sound
pretty miserable, even though
a scout's having the time of his life.
so the question then becomes:
how can we scouters help
parents prepare
for how they're going to feel
once they've dropped their scouts off at camp
and returned home for a very,
very quiet and sometimes
anxious week?
being separated from your child for this length of time
is a new challenge for every parent,
even though
many others have gone through it before
and try to be as supportive as possible.
it really comes down to the way
that you end up feeling
and acknowledging that this causes
most parents at least a little bit
of anxiety and distress,
that it's a normal part of your child
growing up, that it's temporary
and you're going to feel better about it
is going to help.
as somebody who's gone to summer camp for decades,
I understand that
most scouts, especially younger ones,
will experience some level
of homesickness and they're going to experience
some ups and downs because camp is challenging-
and it ought to be. it's a great challenge
for them, but what you need to
understand as a parent is that
his fellow scouts and the
scouters that are with him and the camp staff
are all working hard
to make this challenge
a positive experience,
and scouts get a lot
out of it year after year
after year. while you're concentrating
on getting your scout ready
to go to camp.
prepare yourself too.
here's some ways that you can do just that.
the first one sounds pretty
easy to understand,
but it bears a little explanation,
and that is, first of all, as a parent, think positively.
the overwhelming
percentage of scouts have a
typically great time at summer camp.
they absolutely thrive on it
and they come home happy.
your positive attitude about that
is important, because if
you're going to be anxious about it and you're going to worry about it,
you're going to communicate that to them
during the preparations. whether you like it
or not, they're going to kind of get that message.
so instead of discussing
your worries or how much you're going to miss them
or you don't know
how you're going to deal with this week,
talk about the new experiences
that your scout will have at camp
and all the positive potential involved.
now, anxiety usually comes
from something that we don't know
about or understand.
so make sure
to ask the scouters who are going to camp
with your scout
all the questions you like-
and there are no silly questions,
really, there are none.
if you have a concern
or an anxiety or worry about
exactly what's going to happen at camp,
all the scouters who's going
and sit down and
ask them all of those questions.
get them to explain things to you
and it's going to make you feel better.
it's always better to ask than to worry,
and I have talked with a lot of parents
sending their scout down to camp
for the first time
who are concerned that I'm going to think they're silly
or they're overreacting
or that they're asking
questions that I haven't heard before.
it goes a long, long way
if you can sit down,
be patient with a parent
and do your best
to answer all of the questions that they may have.
now, as a parent,
you need to understand and respect
the way that
your scout will be communicating with you
while they're at camp.
now, in the age of cell phones and things
you know, it's going to depend a lot upon
the way that the
scouters who are taking your scout to camp
are going to work within
that technology.
will they be writing letters
home? will the letters get home
in time? will you be able
to check in with the camp or with the
scouter? look,
if you're really anxious about this
and you're anxious about being
out of touch with your scout
for a long period of time like this,
talk to the scouter about it
and see what you can do
to set up a communication plan
so that you can check in
with the scouter or the scout
and realize that that's
important both to
your state of mind at home
and to your scout's state of mind at camp.
and finally, my suggestion to you
as a parent: if you are
sending your scout off to camp, plant
something wonderful to do while they're away.
you may have siblings at home that you need
to look after. you have your regular daily
routine that you're going to follow and everything.
take advantage of the little bit of freedom
that this is going to afford you
and make some plans. it'll be great.
so I understand that.
look, I know when parents
are anxious about these types of things
and I don't laugh it off.
I don't think you're being silly,
I don't think you're being childish,
because this is a big challenge,
not only for your scout, but it can
be a very big challenge for parents too.
once again,
think positively and, as you're preparing
your scout to go to camp, talk about all the wonderful
things that are going to happen
and the wonderful potential and possibilities
of the week at camp.
try and stay away from telling them
how much you're going to miss them
or how worried you're going to be.
ask the scouters who are going to camp
with your scout all the questions
that you like, because it's always better
to know than to worry about something
that you're not quite too sure about
understand. and plan
the way that you're going to be able
to communicate with your scout. and once again,
ask the folks who are going to camp with them.
and finally, take advantage of the fact
that you're going to have a little bit of freedom
that week too, and plan something great.
my experience over the past couple,
three decades means anything.
what's going to happen is,
at the end of that week of scout camp,
your scout's going to come home feeling confident,
having had a great experience,
and you're going to see that in them
and see the value of this experience
both for them and for you
as a parent.
so all that advice is aimed at
helping parents get prepared for summer camp.
plus, I shared earlier
the ten things that you can do as a scouter
to kind of help prepare yourself
and make that week a great week,
and I hope that helps as you
start the countdown to the best week of the year,
right, the week that you have to go
and spend at summer camp.
hey, if you have a question about it or comment.
get in touch with me and I'm going to tell you
how to do that in just a moment.
music.
thank you so much for listening to this
312th edition
of the scout master podcast.
here's how to keep in touch.
read the blog at scoutmastercgcom
and you can subscribe to receive updates
to the blog by email.
you can also join our vast happy throng
over in the land of social media.
there are 13,000,
can you believe it?
13,000 people who follow us at facebook
and 3500 prolific
pinners
peruse the pultritudinous pictures
we proffer publicly on Pinterest.
you can listen along with the course of
1400 tweeters on twitter
and you can watch us at scoutmastercg
on youtube. but listen
if you can't face. facebook and twitter makes you bitter
and you have no interest in pinterest.
that's alright, bunkie, just send me a good
old fashioned email,
that's right. zoom in to the late
1999 days, dust off your keyboard
and you can get in touch with me
at clark at scoutmastercgcom,
at c-l-a,
r-k-e
at scoutmastercgcom.
now, if all else fails,
the next time you're in the commissioner's office
you'll see a glass dome.
there's a red phone underneath that dome.
no need to dial, just pick up the phone.
I'll be there to answer your questions
by now. it should be abundantly clear
that the scoutmaster blog and the scoutmaster podcast
are in no way official publications
of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor they endorsed or sponsored
by any scouting organization.
hey, it's only me.
I have a microphone and a way to get on the internet
and I'm interested in helping my fellow
scouters and
having a good time
as we go along. right, and speaking of that,
here is our founder,
Sir Robert Baden Powell.
Sir Robert, Good luck to you
and good camping.
Well, I thank you, sir.
Until next time, everyone.